all right hey what's up guys welcome to
date fails I'm so excited because we are
at all things comedy now we have moved I
keep saying we as if there's multiple I
mean my soul still feels homeless but I
have a new home and that's good I'm
sorry all things comedy which is so dope
because now we can stream the show live
on YouTube we can take phone calls so
people could actually call in with
questions now now your guests can't come
in in their [ __ ] pajamas anymore you
still can and that is encouraged
actually but it is it is actually funny
because I'm recording two episodes today
and Paul you're the only man on the show
today I'm the only man in Los Angeles
action no keeping the stuff I'm growing
it out I think you're just so hairy you
can't get you shave in like half an hour
later its back comes right you have
photosynthesis come on I've never seen
you shave once I do don't you laser
though like I so you don't actually
she's right guys don't know that about
girls but sometimes we'll shave and then
we just go out and like the wind blows
and it's cold and then you get goose
bumps
again it's immediate it's funny like
girls will say oh my god I'm so hairy
like they'll say don't touch my legs and
they literally feel there's like no hair
at all there's like maybe one stubble
and she goes I'm disgusting yourself
which is like a shag carpet all skin to
asian skin so there's no you can't
compete like if a guy with this last
girl was Asian her skin is like baby but
soft with like no hair can't compete
with that
it's like this a rock of skin
the Sirocco right very premium because
rock is the most premium brand we have
Asian skin is top-shelf you know thank
you extra for that top shelf I should
introduce you guys instead of just
talking at you and no one knows people
like who's on the show today
well people watching probably know the
person sitting next to me Jen I have to
tell you yesterday was national best
friends day and at like midnight last
night I'm like combing through my photos
trying to find some way I got a tweet
something but it's after midnight and
it's too late and I realized that we've
tweeted like every photo of us together
so many times we need something new we
need to take a new picture we do anyway
this is the fabulous hilarious very
talented comedian and actress Jen star
Jennifer surger I think that's true
actually I think therapists should be
able to prescribe you a person like they
prescribe you a dog I think it's like a
discount on your flight like that should
be just a thing yeah yeah
you can catch Jen and I actually
together on Sunday night at 8 p.m. on
drunk shopping at meltdown it's gonna be
awful I'm very the best way possible I
don't know what's gonna happen I don't
even know it's hosted by Erin darling
and Chris Saint who was on some show
about piercing people he's a piercer did
you know that he's a he's a professional
piercer he Pierce's Pierce's things he's
hot I'm not gonna let him pierce you
think it's gonna be fine but you can
watch us on that that's gonna be amazing
and you've got a what historical roast
coming up a couple of them yeah but I
know the the one I'm most excited about
is probably the professional wrestling
one we're gonna roast you have to roast
its historical roast cero some one of
the Dead
so we're roasting macho-man and I can't
give it away but I will be doing it in a
character you will yeah I get to bring
back like character acting it's gonna be
a lot of fun III think you might do it
as China I'm just gonna guess no just
because I sound like a dude
that's why we're friends we both sound
like mad that's fantastic
you're gonna kill it that because you
actually like know and love wrestling
like a lot of people tweet at me about
wrestling just cuz I'm friends with some
wrestlers but I don't know [ __ ] about
wrestling but you know a lot yeah I know
enough I was because I worked for the
WWE briefly because you used to be a pro
wrestling what yeah I didn't know that I
broke my neck three days into training I
was like well my career's over who are
you gonna fight who wasn't gonna fight
yeah who are you training for I was
training with
Ava Marie why my neck is busted no she's
bad she's really she's like an Instagram
model that occasionally can Russell
fantastic actually sounds wonderful
all right and this guy I just keep I
can't I can't
first of all I have to say that I'm so
glad that we're friends me too and I'm
so glad that you are a comedian because
if you weren't I would have definitely
had sex with you by now and we would not
be friends anymore comedy okay Paula
liya hilarious comedian super funny
actor you're honestly like one of the
funniest off-the-cuff people I've ever
met in my life like your characters this
dude will just be hanging out and he'll
just like break into characters like
multiple characters until I'm literally
peeing my pants laughing you're so funny
I aim to please
we went to the ranch in San Miguel
together last night and did a gig and
Paul just murdered your the you were
amazing oh thank you so are you well you
were hard to follow I was like I can't
follow him what am I gonna do I'm gonna
have to get these people drunk but you
have a film coming out on July 12th
right yeah the dirty coming out
basically everywhere on demand on all
the digital network yeah iTunes
start in it it's so rad and he's also on
an upcoming episode of lady dynamite on
Netflix which is so cool that's cool
yeah it's dreaming now episode 5 Maria
Bamford you're killing the game and you
and I have worked together on so many
things that over at all deaf digital as
well I love people I get it's so funny
all this hard work you put into your
career all I ever get recognized for the
dick the crotch grab the black geez I
guy came up to me last night he goes are
you that chick that made out with that
black dude on my website you're awesome
2k thank you well we should get into it
here's a question I have for you do you
date comics I would not I don't know
I've never dated a comic but like I've
like hooked up with some but I mean I
think there was one comic that we were
hooking up like few pretty often and
then we just like cut it off for you
know no reasons business reasons yeah
interesting how are you how did it start
that you were hooking up is it like one
night after a show you just well I met
her at a coffee bean which is where I
meet all the ladies they start making
Kate's drink them in and she walks in do
they know my drink you know I have met a
lot of if somebody comes in and orders
the same drink as me I'll use that as a
conversation starter that's how the last
homeless guy want to she's like she's
even illah ice-blended extra meth drug
seven days ago isn't that awesome
eight days of sobriety yeah thanks last
night I smelled tequila and I started
shaking
wait so she's a comedian but you met her
at a coffee shop yeah I met her at a
coffee shop and then I randomly started
an open-mic I didn't know she was a
comedian we just had like brief
conversation and then from there I was
like hey I'm doing a show tomorrow do
you want to get on the show so I got her
on the show you know just banger exactly
I'm a piece of [ __ ] but I didn't know
she was like that enemy I just generally
wanted like hear her comedy and I
thought she was cool ask you were you at
all bummed when you found out like you
meet this dope chick at a coffee bean
you're like she's cute and then when you
found out I was a comic yeah cuz when I
find out a guy is like if I meet a hot
guys like I always wanted to try stand
up my vagina goes drier than the Sahara
like wow that's dry as [ __ ] yeah it's
immediately like but you know what I I
actually like if a girl is a comedian
she's really funny then it would be cuz
I can actually enjoy her company and she
can actually like provide jokes and we'd
have a good time but answer so impatient
yeah but if a girl's like so unfunny and
then like I'm hanging out with her and
she'll like add a tag and it's not funny
and like I'll forced to laugh I'm never
really bad forced laugh I mean there's
nothing worse than if you're into
someone and then you see them go onstage
and it's not even if they bum times
comic bomb like a comic will bomb but
other comics think they're really funny
like a Comics comic who's like almost
doing inside jokes for the comics it's
like I can still get down with that but
if you go up and then you're just like
not at all funny or super awkward then
what do you do what would you like you
wouldn't hook up with a comic but you
would hook up with an actor though right
I have yeah would you hook up with a bad
actor hell no
his eye lines like so often tried dating
a porn star and I really wanted to but I
couldn't handle it once I watched his
work not because he's [ __ ] other
girls it turned out he was a really
shitty actor yeah he's such a bad actor
yeah I can't date a bad actor I I will
never I've had girls that I've met that
I've gotten really close to and then
I've seen them act and then I couldn't
talk to him anymore Wow my piece of [ __ ]
yeah no I didn't say anything like she
came to my acting class I've acting
studio that I run with this woman named
Sue Hamilton so her and I are running
this studio and this girl came in to
audit a class and I convinced the SU to
let her take the class for free and get
her to work instead of just sit around
and watch that's cool yeah and she
started to act and it was like so
over-the-top and it was like so theater
star you know what I don't think it was
that like we should get her into porn
like she literally acted like a porn
star over to the adult side you'll be
fine I just want to say that I do have
some friends who work in porn though who
are actually like decent actors like
sometimes I even told one guy that I'm
friends with I go you know I watched
some of your porn and you're a really
good actor you should try to be like
real a star like you should get out of
there and and he was like but right now
I get to act and [ __ ] people like that's
a good point it's a good point yeah yeah
so back to your comedian so you so you
meet her you find out she's a comic you
get her on a show to try to bang her
good move I like that yeah and she she
wasn't very funny and like her jokes
just like didn't make any sense like she
would just do like a random act outside
of nowhere it like she was like cells
walking down the street you know just
walking just walking and then I'm just
like well it's funny when you put it
that way
I just
comedy didn't appeal to me yeah but like
she was still I'll still attract it to
her you know and she said she was a
comic but she was wasn't doing as many
shows a lot of people that say they're
comics but they're not really
aggressively you know like yeah it was
more of a hobby for her so that's why I
gave her a pass yeah you know like we
still start hooking up and stuff and
then once she took comedy seriously wait
so once she started doing comedy more
seriously though then that was it yeah
it's hard to date anyone you work with
I've talked about this on the show
before but I just think it's a slippery
slope it's like you start dating someone
you work with and it could be fantastic
like dating a comic on some level it's
great right because you're both funny
you can give you the time networking
yeah and you get the job but then if it
doesn't end well and then you have to
see them it's like being in high school
except they're like doing it on Twitter
can we not listen I know I agree though
the Twitter thing it's so funny how like
social media has changed the way that I
date to the point of like I'm terrified
even text guys I think you're
intimidating oh yeah like if you text a
dude like hey come over like a dude will
screenshot it post it on Facebook and be
like yo look at this girl trying to [ __ ]
me well okay I just wanted you to
lighter like my pilot is actually not a
euphemism
I really do need a guy on fire trying to
later eater of the me lighting my hair
on fire story is that I set up a camera
okay because I did I was like I'm gonna
make a funny video where I go to light
my pilot light but because my pilot
light is so low to the ground I got a
head down so I can make like a funny
joke about it like yo bet you didn't
know when your girl lights a pilot light
it's gonna be ass up head down like
whatever like something stupid really
bend down to get in there I guess stick
my head in the furnace I actually got
the pilot light lit funny so I was like
I got to do a better video
I like the match and then I'm like
holding the match on purpose like where
I know it'll look good on camera and
that's when I lit my hair on fire so I
didn't even need to light the thing
again and then I had to go
get a haircut did get like the most
likes of any video ever posted my hair
smelled by the way like if you've ever
let your hair on fire it smelled like a
dying bot like it smell like a dead body
nowadays I couldn't get it out awful it
wasn't hot I'm glad we had this talk
Jen what's going on with you when you
came here you said you'd left your
boyfriend crying on the ground
it was so nonchalant yeah he's crying
I'm like if I seem flat effect today
it's because I I don't make it like a
big hidden secret like I said I like
suffer from massive anxiety and so I
don't do it often but I had to take half
of a xanax last night which compared to
what I used to have to be on like I used
to be on enough drugs to kill Keith
Richards all prescribed but so I took
like half of one last night but the
problem is is when I take one I give
zero [ __ ] about everything and so I
don't even know what we were fighting
about but he was yelling I was talking
and finally I was like I can't deal with
you right now I'm like I need a break
and then I couldn't be talked out of it
and he's like I told him you needed a
break you make a street car desire on me
and I'm like this isn't helping and I'm
just completely like it's borderline
stoned you just don't care yeah you're
stuck when you're on xanax you're just
like or and I feel like when you're on
you know a middle range it is the only
time I don't go psycho I need to be on
something like that because I think that
it would help me from like not blowing
up guys because I blow up guys I like I
blow up your bones like a crazy person
you need to chill button like one of
those easy buttons like
would be like remember the night that we
went out with the remote-control
vibrator and I wore the vibrator and
every time I tried to talk to a guy and
I would say something stupid Jen would
have vibrator
oh when we read into comics Brady
Matthews how do you wear a vibrator Shay
not easy you gotta have strong Kegel
muscles okay nobody shaped like a
mouthpiece sorta so like there's a part
in front and a part inside of you and so
she's led a walk she kind of walked like
Danny DeVito and Batman Returns just not
act turned on at all by this story I
came twice I feel like I need like some
kind of patch that I could wear that
would release just little bursts of
xanax in to me when Jen hits a button so
that when I like when I text her I'm
like oh my god I'm blowing up his phone
I'm going crazy she could just hit that
button and it would just show me the
[ __ ] I need a chill-out shot-caller
didn't work we did we really did so you
say you took Cody you need a break and
then he cried and then you stepped over
him to leave while he's crying
yeah like she's yeah we all know I'm not
gonna take a break I think can take my
break didn't want him yelling at him I
I'm so adverse to conflict where I'm
like that's cool like you and I have
fought no I got the other day Jenny and
I had a fight by I had a fight Jen text
me a peace sign
I sent her like a thumb up and then
she's like maybe we need a break I'm
like I think we do love you throw away
we need
all the time next morning at like 11
a.m. I'm looking through my new
headshots am i dying to send them to
china maker on a break i can't be on a
break from you i already miss you it's a
lemon a it's been like 11 hours it's not
a dramatic person will go that's cool
and walk away but that's like worse than
like actually being combative just like
being so dismissive it like hurts so
much
yeah but i wonder if there's an animal
in the animal kingdom then instead of
fighting they're just like [ __ ] it they
walk away oh my god I don't know but if
I could find that animal I would try to
breed it with myself perfect human he
goes I don't know why you never noticed
I have green eyes before we're putting
out somebody he looks at me yesterday
and goes wow you still have green eyes
and you're over 30 she's not a kitten
your eyes just change to brown or
something like I've never seen a 40 50
year old person with green eyes I've
never seen them I'm looking for the
questions our people are asking
questions relationship questions
oh there's anyone that's asking us
relationship questions after the first
block of this show should really Rhian
their lives boyfriend is crying at home
he's probably still crying
I dated a porn star Paul Paul meets
comics at coffee bean and blows him
outward and He pours about what he finds
out they're actually doing comedy
my favorite thing about your stories
though of these two girls is that both
of them like you met them when you found
out what they do and then you helped
them both you got them both
yeah I I always I'm very helpful like if
I see someone and they if I can offer
some type of help I always do it without
them even asking but you pay it forward
because that [ __ ] does come back yeah
like I was like even when I was shooting
dirty there was this one chick she was
Asian she had good skin and she she was
like yeah I want to get my sag card and
I was like yeah you want to be in my
movie she was like really I was like
yeah I'll put you in my movie and then I
called the director I'm like look boy
you got to do me a favor
and she hasn't booked anything and now
she'll never work again thing is a
tricky thing it's like you want to be in
but you don't yeah
I can't work not on sags you piss off
the Union I'm like I got her in the film
and then she just never talked to me
again after that so I was like you know
what I helped her out I did when I
wasn't upset I was like you know I did
my part I helped somebody yeah yeah she
was attractive yeah I would have liked
to got to know her better but you know
that was sad something about who she was
you know yeah I think so that's most of
LA do you guys have any recent date
fails that you want to share beside well
Jenn you had one today but I feel gen
your your relationship is extremely
tumultuous can we say no it's not it's
to all to dramatic one end bumpy no it's
not it's not at all but no not bumpy
like I ever think you guys will break up
for a minute I really don't in fact the
brake thing is funny cuz I can't even
believe he believed you but there's no
you guys are so quick I think you guys
have you guys are bordering on what I
had with the guy that I dated for a year
that my friends refer to as the gone
girl guy because
when I think of you - it always makes me
think of the movie gone girl and I'm
like Cena fan - oh wow the movie gone
girl like they basically are both insane
but she's she's so crazy that she she
frames him for murder
oh and then she ends up basically it's
not like that at all it's just I one of
us is much more dramatic than the other
and it's not me which is a switch
because usually the girls supposed to be
dramatic or a little more dude like I am
a hundred percent more to life with
someone with boobs yeah I think that I'm
really dude like because I'm surface
dude and I'm like a tomboy but when it
comes to like sensitivity I'm so [ __ ]
sound yeah if I'm like extremely so then
I go way to the girl side yeah yeah I'm
not that girl I'm like Kate don't answer
his phone I give you great advice which
you never take if I listen to Jen's
advice I'd probably have like four
proposals right now yeah that's probably
really what it is really true though
that the guys who ignore won't leave you
alone 1,000% I have a couple guys right
now that I'm like I don't ignore anyone
you saw me yesterday answering people I
find yeah I was so shocked by that
I was shocked she's so nice and I don't
get it
Kate would be like yeah hey you know
there's this guy texting me he's he's
being really rude and I was like really
and she goes yeah let me respond yeah
being rude I said he just basically like
what happens is sometimes guys will not
give up trying to hang out with me and
I'll try to find every way to tell them
I'm not into it like I'll say I'm seeing
someone I'll say I'm not interested I'll
say whatever you say I'm dead
I stopped asking which is a great
question like as a man if you're into a
girl and you keep trying and she you
know she's she knows she's not into you
what is the nicest way she can just put
you out of your misery so you stop say
it we need to take a break because most
that's not happening take a break from
knowing my phone number take my phone
this guy I've gone crazy on guys to try
to get them to break up with me and they
wanted me more that's true sometimes
well some guys I dated a guy that's so
into crazy the more crazy I would be
like he'd hate me but then the sex would
just get hotter and hotter and it was
like oh because it was just turning more
and more into hate sex every time we'd
have sex I be like this is the last time
and he'd be like then it better be good
it was the best sex I ever had it still
to this day by the way it's great for a
play talk is impeccable so to this day
it's like sometimes I hit that guy up
when I'm not hooking up with anyone or
if I'm trying to stop hooking up with
someone I'll hook that guy up I'll be
like can we just walk and then if he
says no I'll start being really mean to
him I'm like good cuz the more mean I am
to him the more I know he thinks about
it so wait Jenna how you you said you're
mean to guys and they want you more yeah
that's that's how she fat shamed her
boyfriend into getting in shape it
worked
he's in great shape now this guy was
never fat by the way a professional
athlete he was never fat he plays
baseball like he picked the one sport
besides sumo wrestling you could be fat
and be considered that is true I will
give you that but he was never bad
a little on the Husky er side of in
shape he's built for power underhandedly
in a way that I call them chunk that's a
good workout plan you should like make a
tape Chad because that's one of the
questions that I've been tweeting a
little bit about this guy
I don't normally I'm not a bachelorette
watcher but I decided just to be up to
date you know and relevant because she's
a good friend and I hurt my neck and so
I was like Kate come hang out with me
and be a civilian for me watch The
Bachelorette and play with kittens which
are two things if you want to see me
almost [ __ ] my pants go on my periscope
for you to watch me trying to hold
kittens at Jen's house I'm terrified
she's scared there's a guy on the show
named Chad I told Kate I was like you
have to watch this guy it's your future
ex-boyfriend she's like you're gonna
marry this guy and divorce them and I'm
like why and she's like he's a psycho
when he get met in jail Tuesday night
like it's not going well
he punched somebody I didn't say Tuesday
Tuesday night yeah spoilers for anyone
who has not caught up with a bachelor
out now true now for like two and a half
minutes so he got
kicked off the show he got another guy
chosen over him he went on a two-on-one
date describe him for people who don't
know what chad is like chad the kind of
guy that walks around with lunch meat in
his pockets because he's got to eat
every 25 minutes to feed his muscles
they said he's 275 pounds that's a load
of crock he's like 225 at most
yeah but also shows daddy his veins all
he does is work out and eat he's on the
rock work he's really hot that said he
clearly came off his cycle too fast to
be on the show and so he's going through
any kind of withdrawal that like a
person who's been on steroids would do
we're just completely irrational you
want to fight everyone and everything
and that's where Chad is Chad went on a
two-on-one date which is in case that's
not awkward enough it was they went to
the woods with this girl what does a bar
in LA that I think is a great they know
they went out into the forest okay idea
no this is her idea to go for a hike
I'm like when we said we wanted Chad to
take hike this is not we had a mind but
what you're catching on it's fine so
they know and then she like take turns
hanging out with them the one dude
besides Chad spent his entire alone time
with her complaining about chat like a
[ __ ] okay and then Chad basically spent
the rest of his time denying all the
accusations that said [ __ ] said about
him if I don't watch the show she
decides that she believes the pansy boy
had more who by the way he's not a pansy
he's a former Marine super not one that
I like super tres short one with the
tattoos like finally he's like five
three it's his name I don't care if it
looks like Super Mario before I eat the
bus if you're watching pansy boy but
he's a tattletale that's a turn-on yeah
not cool too bad so anyways Chad gets
kicked off they leave chat in the woods
they don't really address what happens
to Chad but then all of a sudden you see
Chad like walking through the woods by
himself witless whistling no whistling
like very Kill Bill ish Cape Fear
whatever walking through the [ __ ]
woods and he shows up back at the dudes
house like the guy's house that they
were all living in by himself and he's
like knocking on the door he puts his
fingers on the door and like drags them
down and that's where they cut it come
on do they think the producers are
telling directed that's great the only
reason I think he might be really crazy
is because on one episode of the show he
was eating a raw sweet potato like an
apple just eating bites out of a bra
yeah potato who does that that's been a
thing lately well it's a lot I've been
doing that my cousin came to my house
and took a tomato and put a little bit
of dressing on it and ate it like a now
that's fine that's a tomato tomato soft
skin have you eaten missed a raw sweet
potato out but it's like eating a rock
oh man I don't know man I don't know but
I have to say that even though I don't
condone violence or steroid use
but Chad call her I do like the fact
that you are trying to take out all the
other guys on the show I think if you go
on the show you're automatically a
gigantic loser and I'm sorry to my
people that I know that have been on the
show I'm sorry to the person I know made
no show now no you're not I'm not really
kinda dude you are a douchebag Jordan
but I mean should I not have said his
name I'm not obligated to any contract I
auditioned to be on The Bachelorette
yeah really yeah we did it look as a bit
but it was hilarious when they wanted
her and they're still calling her
admission like you show up and they ask
you questions yeah well what happened is
Jen and I went to a casino where they
were having an open call and I wore a
bikini and I pretended that I was just
going back to my room from the pool
no one questioned it they were like oh
you're at the Potomac yeah like the
third floor to like some forums to get
to that but no one questioned it I was
like I was just walking by and you guys
are having auditions for what sexiest
yet in the world oh yes okay to fill out
this long like eight pages of paperwork
yep it was like why did your last
relationship end why did your marriage
end and she just wrote see photo because
everyone else is like in suits and ties
and dresses like a cocktail party it's
like break dancing to like will not
break dancing she's twerking and
everyone's just staring it's hilarious
yeah and then I went in and then I got
with the producer one of the producers
were the first thing she said to you was
I was really hoping I'd get you I saw
you out there and I was like I have to
have that one wow I think I wish a man
would say that but the so she
interviewed me and the first thing she
asked she's like so why are you in a
bikini and I was like well I was at the
pool and she was like okay let's try
that again
why are you she wasn't stupid
and then she was like so is this a joke
to you or do you really want to be on
the show and I was like well I would be
willing to be the Bachelorette but I
want the guys to take me on real dates
they can afford in their regular clothes
I want to see where they really live I
want like the blue-collar treatment like
I want them to be real I don't want to
be like I'm a dentist I wouldn't be like
I'm an out-of-work actor trying to be a
TV host and
real story and she's like greater is
nice to meet you know you're fantastic
bye I never thought I'd hear from them
again but then they did reach out and
they really like me they want me to be
on The Bachelor though Jerry do it not
unless I was doing it for like a hidden
purpose like don't know about it I don't
think I would do it I don't think and
also definitely they would never ask me
if they look at my Twitter for because
I've been tweeting a lot about my
feelings on the Bachelorette and just
I'm just I'm not a fan but Jen went with
you to audition also I didn't audition I
support human I helped her fill out her
her resume her paperwork
I helped answer that we were crying we
are calling this out it was really funny
yeah we're gonna answer one fan question
and then I want to hear your date fail
story because we're actually almost out
of time which is crazy so fast can you
ask questions about Chad someone said
yes you can absolutely ask questions
about Chad we don't know him personally
but I'll be glad to psychoanalyze
someone I can people still call yeah
people can still call I have to admit
that I would go on one date with Chad
just because I'd be curious to see if
he's as big a douchebag in real life as
they edited he'd go on multiple dates
with Chad become obsessed with I
probably would fall in love with Chad
and then you'd blow up his phone and I
would tell you you were crazy and then
he would send you shirtless like nail
marks chad is exactly the kind of guy
that I would catch like major feelings
is so [ __ ] awful that I would somehow
convince myself I could change yes yeah
yeah
Chad called me I think Kate does is Kate
internalizes um he internalizes other
people's problems and puts it on herself
like there's something wrong with her
and I'm like no there's something
completely wrong with him yeah well I'm
Achaia I'm a product of divorce are your
parents divorced Paul no they're still
together see that's why you're you're a
good functioning and Jen your parents
are still together I have that do it or
not they should be remains to be seen
props to my dad though because my mom is
going through crazy menopause right now
so - - that's hard
is hard are you I'm hanging up on a
break commercial here's the one question
we're gonna answer
well the question I think this person is
joking how do you keep sex fresh and
alive after the first date which is a
funny question but for real you've been
in a relationship for a year now I was
in a long relationship Paul have you
ever been in a long relationship never
okay mom's relationship has been like
weird I've said hey do you want to be my
girlfriend or just soand that you're
just hooking up with no you never really
established you guys are dating someone
that you are exclusive with I'm seven
months uh yeah the sex is still hot for
the first yeah I think I mean how do you
keep a sex how do you keep sex fresh
they're like how do you keep why I
haven't okay that's an interesting
question then why have you not committed
to anyone else and is it have to do with
sex no I'm really picky uh-huh and I
always if I'm dating a girl I always
think would my mom like her because my
mom is a really controlling woman oh
yeah and she's a lot of say yeah she's a
lot of say on the plane she goes wet
audio they start speaking Arabic am i
trying to turn off and I was like she
was literally saying things like listen
call me when you get home and like
she'll sing in Arabic but to the
untrained ear Arabic just sounds like
terrorist activity like I know she's
giving him the access codes all right
I'm not gonna make you go deeper into
why you've never committed to anyone
yeah something else I mean that's the
simplest thing is I just I mean I would
like to be with someone for a long time
abuse women exclusively and every time I
like seasonally I'm really physically
attracted to it just never really works
out mhm and then I'll meet a girl that
I'm not that attracted to but she's like
so enemy and then I mean looks do play a
big part and you want if people say it
doesn't they're full of [ __ ] or at least
chemistry does yeah yeah because I've
hooked up with guys that I looked at
them I'd be like I don't be that into it
but then we'll hook up and we'll have a
crazy chemistry and it'll be great
mm-hmm well just also I think
personality plays in a lot with you Kate
you know any mean like you have to be
able to bond over stuff yeah and I'm
really attracted to talent like yeah
because I like when people are
vulnerable with you yeah well yeah maybe
yeah yeah I'm still working through that
with my therapist I mean drugs well tell
me your worst date fail Paul cuz we got
to get out of here okay I met a girl on
plenty of fish and I met her in person
and that's old-school plenty of fish
plenty office I was like who wants to
date someone that's called plenty office
she's just being off I always thought
plenty of fish was a Christian dating
site until very recently I had no idea I
thought it fish had something to do with
the Jesus day yeah
life has changed right now yeah I
thought pani on fish was like JDate for
Christians it's not though
it's it's I think it's for all religions
I think it's for all different sizes of
people it should be called plenty of
whales because a lot of the women out
there chemistry I failed chemistry and
no but I I am I mean when I go on a date
with somebody like if I'm not physically
attracted to them I will look at them
and think oh well I can enjoy this
person's company they could be my
friends looks like I've dated guys I
swear to god that treat me really well
and don't look that good and Joan is
like that's aesthetics we can fix that
oh man so I met this girl and she was a
little bit bigger than what I expected
yeah which is fine yeah I'll just take
her to the grocery store and park really
far away you know I I ended up taking
her to the woods which is a bar not the
actual forest so I met her there and she
was like really cute but she was like so
we started talking and then five minutes
into our conversation she just started
acting like really [ __ ] like agitated
yeah and like she was like asking me
questions than answering the questions
and then I realized that um she just
wanted me to just listen to her like she
goes so where are you from well I'm from
Ohio the end I actually did this did you
play sports cuz I did this and like
she's kept talking now it's like
listening and I think there's a point I
went to the bathroom and she kept like I
told I was like I must go to bathroom
and she just kept talking so I was like
okay that's what to the bathroom came
back Wow and then she was immediately
like right when I sat down she was like
hey so um do you want to get out of here
and um you know and she starts doing
this yeah she's I rate her pelvis area
and that made me like nobody don't smile
just stay by keiko do you wanna don't
smile nice teeth you can't show your
teeth because it's just like - no I feel
like you do that any guy be like yeah
but like there was a party like I say
yeah with such a deep voice and you sit
at the next table over and you just film
and we won't tell them and I you want to
get out of here do the elliptical I call
it doing the elliptical there's a part
of me that was like you know what I know
she's done meth and I or some drug I
know she's on a drug and I also know
that she - so I was like okay sure let's
go to my house so we went to my house
and she clearly she's on drugs and she's
she's attractive and she's she's down so
right when we walk in I take off all my
clothes and and then she kind of like
looks at me and then she's like you know
what I think I got it go yeah no no but
like I had like my underwear on and
in good shape but I felt like all of a
sudden the meth wore off ask you one
quick question about this please I I
just have to ask because I've had guys
do this too and it's like we're in your
guy brain when you get to the apartment
do you just this is a girl you've never
hooked up with before you guys haven't
even started making out there's been no
foreplay right no foreplay
you still automatically just strip naked
cuz you're like so sure your body's
doing the naked man
two out of three times a girl love sex
with you three actually one out of three
this that was this guy's move he would
come in make himself comfortable two
girls place strip down naked and one out
of three girls would have sex with him
we're talking about Neil Patrick Harris
Harris tried to do it though and it
didn't work for him that was the whole
the whole point of that this is so crazy
to me because I just I mean I've had
guys that I literally have invited over
for sex and then when they get there I
might change my mind and not have sex
with them sometimes I change my mind I'm
a girl were entitled there's nothing
wrong with that but I take note Stanford
she's she's giving me all these signals
up so I was like all right she wants to
hook up and then like we we got like
right when we got into the house I
decided to take a risk you know like um
I had pocket threes and I went all-in
thinking you know you got naked and she
saw you and she just no no like um like
I I was in decent shape at the time of
people who can't who are watching this
Paul is super handsome
I think I even told Jeb before oh my god
it's Anders right way too bad Paul's a
comic he's hot like seriously like your
heart
yeah so but then you guys didn't hook up
no we so I guess her drugs were off and
I took off my shirt and then I started
like unbuckle my belt and I took off my
pants and I was like hey you know we got
a pool if you want to like swim or
something too and then she was like I
think I'm gonna go and like she said
like really dramatic like [ __ ] Amy
Adams and like somebody and then I was
like oh what's wrong and she was like I
actually have a meeting with this
manager and I'm like you know and then
she was like I mean I mean if you have
your headshot I can like bring it to
them I'm standing there like [ __ ]
Oliver Twist I kind of make it like
great classic LA date fail girl shows up
[ __ ] up on who knows white-nose bat
wants to give you the fake gyrate thing
I've never that gyrate I've never had
anyone do that and like that only means
yeah all right I think that was one of
the best date fails I give you props
especially because she asked for your
headshot at the well can I just say this
was super fun you both look great on
camera which is really important oh so
do you honey yeah great thank you you
have green eyes all right jen has
perfect teeth and you have eyebrows so
we're killing it the three of us perfect
teeth Jen I try really I have braces you
should see your name oh wow anyway
listen this has been date bells you guys
have been Paul alaya Jen Sturgill where
can they find you I'm on Twitter
Instagram all that Facebook at Paolo I
123 and dirty comes out July 12 on all
did you
platforms watch for that yeah and Jen my
couch crying yeah no you can find me on
Twitter at Jennifer's stores or
instagrams the same thing I'm gonna be
at meltdown comics quite a bit I mean
both that might be my new home I'm gonna
be doing the historical roast there
we're gonna be doing the drunk shopping
this weekend where we actually get to
sell off items that our exes gave us
gonna be amazed how do you sell herpes I
don't know how to I just want to say if
you're not following Jen on Twitter her
Twitter is [ __ ] hilarious it's so far
as yours
oh thanks or shows you guys and you guys
all know you can follow me at Kate cue
funny I will tweet a photo of us so you
can find these two and this has been
really fun thank you guys for being here
at see you next time on date fails